um okay hi guys it was before I need to
know I'm gonna ask you some insane
questions okay and this is in this one
issue on the third page what happened in
if you're no um no okay so so for the
most part I think all eyes are kind of
on you guys you know it's where she's
like and with Tom Holland because people
are looking at Nick Fury and they're
slow K so Nick here we got Dustin right
he's mad at a picture for the last five
years but now he's back mm-hm like what
plans does Nick Fury have going for
because I feel like the wheels turned
well the end the plan right now he's
trying to figure out you know what
exactly happened he kind of knows who's
gone he does know that Tony Stark left
him sort of a directive that this kid is
the next thing you know that I'm leaving
everything I know to him because I
believe he's the one a neighborhood you
know you gotta grow up some
responsibility Wow okay I think I'd like
to be the layers over in the movie if
like Nick Fury said that to the Spider
Man you monetize okay so so Jake
Gyllenhaal I'll try not to wear it out
um Mysterio was amazing if you could
fight any other Avenger who would it be
my gosh
well I don't really fight any of the
Avengers because this one Peter and I
fight together thankfully because Nick
Fury joins us up because we have to go
fight the elemental creatures so in that
sense I know if I really want to find
any of the other Avengers thank you and
Doctor Strange could have a pretty dope
yeah any battle could be like what's
real what's not yeah whose cape is
cooler yeah I think it'd be pretty sweet
I mean I haven't dr. strange show up and
face off against Mysterio we're gonna
fight yeah yeah now they said earlier we
need like a new orator because Tony's
gone now okay well then we'll set it up
like like Nicolas gets new Avengers
speechwriter well I mean if it was like
Nick Fury's Bohr he's like you know what
I think it'd be cool to just see
Mysterio fight someone so then like like
oh you can pick the Incredible Hulk
just like go fight the Incredible Hulk
let's just see what happens I think okay
you got a girl yeah meet captain mom I
grow up Mysterio do the families kids
actually Mysterio lost his family and
the other came from well that's that was
my next question is is for the character
Mysterio obviously looking at what we
seen with the trailer and everything
like he's a dynamic character yeah so
can you tell us about that dynamic
nature of hysteria well I mean it starts
with the cop but costume I mean that is
pretty dynamic in itself has a lot of
different elements to it actually
borrows from a lot of different ideas
from a lot of the Avengers in an
interesting way but he's dynamic I think
because he's smart you know he has
powers but I think his intelligence is
his ultimate superpower so
and I think that's really I think he
when he first arrives he's very confused
about where he is like there are a lot
of things about this earth though they
share a lot of different things there
are cultural things they don't share
there are obviously superheroes that
they don't share he doesn't really know
where he is so it's kind of learning as
he goes in a lot of different ways but I
just think he's he's fascinating and
he's got a great name yeah I've always
kind of dug the name of Styria
yeah yeah it's like okay kind of a fun
fact in the comics Mysterio actually
well I don't want you to say that
because it's kind of a not really a
spoiler for the movie which is kind of a
crazy thing um and the comics Mysterio
is like he's a straight-up villain and
there's one story called oh man Logan
where he tricks Wolverine into killing
all the x-men it's pretty well yeah it
was pretty cool anyway it's always the
future there's always a future I would
want to see that and I think it I think
it'd be awesome I'm sorry I'm a fan
first and like a youtuber second yeah so
yeah so it's it's it's awesome to me
great yeah so so for the character of
Nick Fury um minor man is out of the
picture right like there's no more Tony
Stark Vineyards in-game all that's done
do you see Nick Fury now these back
looking at Peter Parker who we can just
kind of assume is probably lost without
Tony Stark being there to kind of guide
him and mentor him do you see him as
being almost kind like a mentor source
to Peter kind of I'm Sara Lee becoming a
full-on new Iron Man but someone who can
kind of lead him in the direction of
being a new year
I guess maybe we'll call him an
influencer more so than mentor like
Instagram to help kind of leading this
way that way we're assessing other
people within the universe you know
talking about what's going on yeah he's
been he's been going like I've been gone
you know so I'm really trying to figure
out what my new normal is in
who I need to recruit what I need to do
and how I need to go about it
yes happening love about new cures oh
it's like he's like you have a job to do
why can't you just get it done yeah I
love that about it well and that's all I
mean meant or not there are so many
things that everyone has to deal with
he's got a big threat coming on earth
and he's like how could you not do it
and it's a totally logical thing well
yeah I mean like like you got Nick Fury
who like ran shield right so it's like
this needs to be done
somebody somewhere gets it done and
suddenly like you know after Winter
Soldier we saw that like there is no she
already asked us it was kind of a Yoda
so so my final question here all right
who would your all's favorite Avenger
and why is it for Wow's great interview
so yeah but for elaborate ruse you're
all favorite Avenger favorite event
yeah you can't say yourself no well I'm
not an event well I mean kind of like
you've kind of lead them a little bit
sort of I'm just a master manipulator
Natasha was always my favorite because I
recruited she was around even though
then I'm so far I'm not at her origin
story moving she's she's like the person
that I was closest to if I'm a favorite
it's sort of split between two and I'm
thinking about I'm sort of tossing about
there are certain things I like about
all of them
I do love Doctor Strange I do love all
the things in Doctor Strange and what
are strange can do
okay he didn't ever you don't have a
card meeting pay dues I should I then I
should say something like I really think
I know what they're gonna do with Carol
Danvers but anyway thanks guys
appreciate it cool right yeah it was
like so that's that's so just from the
comics to get to be that graphic and
abstracted yeah well that's the reason
to make movie not gonna go to the first
question is it's like this is your
second spider-man film so directing the
first one learning from that going into
the second one what do you think was
like the biggest thing that you picked
up from or at least the most important
thing you think he picked up in the
first one that's a good question and
it's a funny thing because on the first
movie I had never done something of that
scale before so I didn't really know
what to expect
and with that comes like a little bit of
freedom where you're like so naive you
you're not even sure what you should be
worrying about and so the second movie I
I knew everything that I was supposed to
be worrying about and so I was a lot
more worried the whole time because you
have to you know you feel like you
really have to get everything right yeah
well that's that's to me that's really
interesting because I look at that whole
concept and I'm like okay like if you
look at the first film you look at the
second film you see this like gradual
progression of Peter and then you bring
in somebody who's like as dynamic as
Jake Gyllenhaal yeah like what was that
like bringing like a hugely talented
actor into a pool of existing hugely
talented actors and actresses well I
think it was really exciting for Jake
like we really get along and and talked
about the multiple layers to his
character and I think it was um I think
it was fun for him to to be in this
crazy heightened world of the MCU and to
really be able to just sort of show off
what he can do because he's so so
talented it's great as the director
there's nothing better than working with
great actors because if they make
everything so so easy yeah so here's my
question
with all the new properties everything
coming in if you could direct any one of
them which one would it be you want to
say like always it's a Spider Man I have
to be loyal to spider-man really right
there yeah
watching yeah watching over a watching
over a magazine but I mean I don't know
I mean like there's there's a whole
bunch of possibilities there but I'm
curious because it seems like you mesh
so well with a spider-man concept sorry
that book is the wrong way around I mean
if you look at it the other way around
it's backwards that should be the cover
should I have no idea I don't know what
to tell you magazines
I think that's Universal Wow anyway
yeah no no but now I mean that's that's
that's just kind of my thing because you
really seem to mesh with like spider you
are really all about action go okay
no but you you really mesh well with
like the spider-man concept I I mean I
was felt like I could relate to
spider-man there's something so great
about him where he just seems like a
regular regular person and no matter no
matter what he's going through it's it's
he didn't ask for any of this and so
he's always juggling those
responsibilities with his personal life
and just something so relatable about
spider-man that I am I don't know it's
really it's really inspiring to me yeah
well for the character of Nick Fury he
was more of like a serious character
like traditionally over the course of
the MC who has largely been mostly a
serious character in this film there's
more comedic elements yeah I mean well
he's put in a unusual situation
definitely a situation he's never been
in before and that just inherently lends
itself to some funny moments I mean he's
the guy who supposed to know everything
you know he's the guy who created the
Avengers he's the guy who's he's the
watcher on the wall but yeah for the
first time in his life you know he's
been gone for five years and he's trying
to catch up that's you know he's pissed
off about it but that lends itself to
some funny funny moments yeah man well
ok this is kind of my last and kind of
my big question here is is spider-man
far from home was the follow-up to
Avengers in-game and I think a lot of
people are looking at this like okay
whatever questions we didn't get
an in-game we're hoping you're gonna get
answered in the part from home yeah at
the very least it'll be a send-off to
everything that's happened for the last
10 years
what's that pressure like I mean I I was
one of the people who like knew
everything that was going to happen in
infinity war an end game and this is
interview with the Russos where they're
saying that endgame was the first movie
where they didn't have to worry about
the future of the Marvel Universe I was
like well great guys thanks I do so just
as I you know as I was fighting out all
the crazy things that they were doing I
was like mmhmm okay so half of the
universe disappears okay and then they
come back five years later okay okay how
we gonna deal with that okay you know it
it it's fun it's like a really creative
challenge to deal with all these all
these big issues while still maintaining
the tone of your own movie
yeah well that's one of the things I
kind of want to point out too you know
for before I get out of here that that's
one the cool thing I want to point out
to you because that was a question that
I sort of had is it was like okay how do
we explain this five-year gap if a lot
of people seem to kind of look the same
can we get an explanation like that is
perfect yeah so hey school news it's
like flight of the navigator remember
flight of the navigator I remember but I
never actually saw it oh yeah this is
really like there's a part where the kid
goes into the woods and he's abducted by
aliens and comes back and he's the same
age but in like many years have passed
oh that's his little brothers like older
than him so I just went back to that is
like how weird would that be you know
dude it worked - man it was it was
amazing like Betty says it's just math
just math yeah well drawn I appreciate
it man yeah yeah yeah woman glad you
like the movie you